an electrician has the following lengths
of cable 23 inches 49 inches and 8 feet
how much cable does he have in feet so
these are the lengths each of these are
the lengths of a cable in inches inches
in feet and we want to know the total
length if you add all of these up and we
need the total length in feet and so the
best way to do that is to convert each
of these lengths into feet and then add
them all up so let's start with this one
right over here 23 inches 23 inches so
it's always important to give have your
intuition give a little bit of a check
on what the answer should look like
there are many inches per foot so when
you convert this into feet you should
have a smaller number there 12 inches
per foot so this should be a small
number this is not even 2 feet 24 inches
would be 2 feet so this should be less
than 2 feet but let's do it
mathematically so to do it
mathematically we want this inches to
cancel out with inches and the way you
do that is you put that in the
denominator so you put that in the
denominator inches so it cancels out
with the inches and so we want feet per
inches or foot per inches I guess I'll
just write F T could be fit feet or foot
singular purl it doesn't matter so how
many feet are there per inches or
another way to think about it how many
inches are there per foot 1 foot is
equal to 12 inches or you could say one
foot for every 12 inches or you could
read this as 1/12 of a foot per inch
either way if we multiply by this if we
multiply this the inches cancel out
that's why we know at least
mathematically if we just did it
mechanically why we shouldn't multiply
by 12 but also should make complete
sense we should be dividing by 12
because when you express this distance
in feet it should be a smaller number so
we should divide by 12 so what does this
give us this is equal to 23 times one is
twenty three over twelve twenty three
over twelve the inches this inches
cancels out with that inches and we're
just left with feet
that is 23 over 12 feet and this is an
improper fraction but I'll leave it as
an improper fraction for now because
they're actually easier to manipulate
and then mix the numbers so that's that
first cable let's do the second one
right here 49 inches so the second cable
is 49 49 inches and we do the same thing
we want to convert it to feet
we have inches in the denominator we
should end up dividing by something
because we want a smaller number 49
inches will be a smaller number of feet
by a factor of 12 so what we care about
is feet per inches and we know that
there's 1 foot for every 12 inches or
1/12 of a foot per inch can be read
either way when you multiply the inches
will cancel out and we will be left with
49 times 1 which is 49 over 12 over 12
feet that is the second cable and then
we have this last cable right here this
8 foot cable so this very last one the
very last one is 8 is 8 feet and if we
want we can convert that into an
improper fraction and at this point
there's two ways we could do it
everything is in feet here it's improper
fractions we could if we want to convert
these into mixed numbers and then add
them up or we convert this into an
improper fraction that has the same
denominator and then add them up and the
easiest way I think is to just have this
with the denominator 12 so 8 feet is the
same thing as what over 12
well what's 8 times 12 it's 96 right 96
divided by 12 is 8 8 is the same thing
as 96 12 these are equivalent let me
make sure this 8 and 96 over 12 is the
exact same thing I picked 12 because
these have 12 in the denominator and
then I said 12 times 8 is 96 so 8 feet
is the same thing as 96 over 12 feet and
now I can add everything up the total
length of cable he has is I'll do it
over here
it's 96 over 12 plus 23 over 12 23 over
12 plus 49 over 12 and everything is in
feet so this answer will give us in feet
we have all of the same denominators are
doing
nominator is 12 the denominator is 12
and so we have to add up 96 plus so our
numerator is going to be 96 plus 23 plus
49
let's add that up over here so 96 23 49
we have to add it up 6 plus 3 is 9 9
plus 9 is 18 1 plus 9 is 10 10 plus 2 is
12 12 plus 4 is 16 so that's 168 so this
expression right here is equal to 168
over 12 which is a valid answer and of
course all of these are in feet so it's
168 over 12 feet but let's write this
now as a mixed number so that we have a
better idea of really how many feet it
is and to do that we just divide 168 by
12 so 12 goes into 168 it doesn't go
into 1 it goes into 16 exactly one time
one times 12 is 12 we subtract 16 minus
12 is 4 bring down the 8 bring down the
8 12 goes into 48 4 times 4 times 12 is
48 and we have no remainder so 168 over
12 is exactly 14 so this is exactly
equal to 14 feet so our electrician our
electrician has exactly 14 feet of cable